foreign
let's go out to Naima in Detroit what's
up Naima
Hi how are you guys thank you for
clicking my call thank you so much for
calling we're doing great what's up
um okay so I have a very interesting uh
situation so my husband and I live in a
duplex um that we purchased about six
years ago we live on the top unit and we
have tenants in the bottom unit we have
two children we're sharing one car right
now that's being leased
um and so we're about fifty three
thousand thousand dollars in Consumer
Debt and we have um we owe about 180 K
on the home and so um the home is not in
the greatest neighborhood like I said we
have two children so we're kind of
outgrowing the home as well and so
um listen to your show I told my husband
if I think we should you know sell the
home and we look to make about you know
anywhere from 100 to 150k on the profit
of the house and so we will be able to
pay off all of our debts we would have a
fully funded emergency fund um able to
get rid of the release and purchase two
cars if we really need
um cash and then also have a down
payment on a future home so it does a
lot and so um he's convinced that we
should keep the home and I kind of feel
like he's kind of gambling our potential
future he feels like it's this unicorn
of investment and after you know x
amount of years you're going to have
like this big payoff and so I've done
like two Financial models to show him
like you know how even if we keep it and
then rent somewhere else that we're
struggling like we're really tight you
know with our budget which doesn't mean
any room for like paying down the debts
or saving for emergency let alone for
the children's future or retirement so
my question is like what can I show him
or do to help him understand
um the necessity to sell the home and
not keep it for a potential payoff later
wow you laid that out beautifully and uh
if you've already tried Financial models
I don't know what's going to convince
this guy other than being his wife and
just sitting him down and being like I'm
scared
I'm not sleeping well we don't have an
emergency fund where 53 000 in debt
we're in a dangerous neighborhood trying
to raise these two kids and I want
better for us and selling this house
would give us a clean slate next week
and we'll be back we'll be investing in
the future in no time but right now we
got to clean up this mess have you just
sat him down and did that instead of
showing excel's red sheets yes I have I
started with that I started with high
emotion you know messing me back out of
it let me send them to myself and I got
other numbers and I've been reading and
we're looking to educate myself to make
sure that I wasn't missing anything and
I'll show them the models as well and he
still believes that you know we should
move out but that we should keep it as a
rental as we're renting and I just told
them that our liability so he wants to
get broker by keeping the mortgage and
then getting another mortgage on top of
the Consumer Debt while having no
savings
we would rent next year for two years
and then get a mortgage after yes we
would eventually have two mortgages on
top of yeah rent plus a mortgage it's
going to increase is not fun yeah
give me an increase in Pay soon and so
he thinks that I'm making more money
something I'm telling like the money
can't go out with the expenses that that
we're basically in the same position
that if we increase our income or we
have less expenses we have all this
extra money to now put towards debt I
mean towards retirement and savings and
things like that
um so I'm just having a hard time
getting through to him also part of that
is he's an architect by trade and he
recently got into real estate
development so I think because he's in
development now he's like looking at all
the numbers and all the potentials and
he's like you know it's entrepreneurial
and he wants to like he wants us to be
you know extremely wealthy and I
appreciate that but I think he wants to
put particularly before the egg and he
wants to just jump into this thing and
hold on to what he's afraid of losing as
he said our only asset well I think
there's something bigger than this name
I I appreciate you wanting to defend him
and think that hey he's he's doing all
these cool things with his new job and
this that that must be what it is he's
looking on these numbers
um I don't think that's it at all
I think he is around some guys that are
ahead of him
um financially and they've got some
rental properties I think he watches too
much YouTube and watches too much
Instagram or Tick Tock and I think he
hears all these dudes flexing about real
estate real estate real estate and he's
over here with the least car
one car and it's like you can't even see
the forest for the trees right
um it's that guy that like hasn't been
to the gym in years but just keeps
putting on tighter shirts because he
feels big inside of them right it's it's
just a strange Flex that's not working I
don't think this has anything to do with
him getting sophisticated or Smarter
with numbers I think it sounds like a
guy who's getting more and more scared
because math doesn't care what you want
math is just math and he's got I'll tell
you this is also scary he has a
brilliant very clear thinking wife
because you've been through all the
numbers you've been through all the
emotions you've been through all the
tracks the the I mean you've done it all
um I I honestly would go back to what
George said that I would do it not in
your home okay I know that sounds weird
but I would take him somewhere
there's something about our homes or
something about places that are familiar
that our brains automates a lot of
things
and sometimes it makes it hard to hear
or hard to learn or hard to see a
different perspective because everything
just gets dumped into a think of it like
a highway that's familiar when you're at
in a road that you've never been on
before every one of your senses is up
and alert where are we what safe where
are we going and so taking them out for
breakfast somewhere y'all getting away
for a weekend and just going to a nice
hotel somewhere whatever
take him away and say I want to plan for
the future for real and I want you to
start that conversation with I'm so
scared I can't breathe
do it no I have a truck I know I know I
know I feel like he needs something as
I'm like I'm looking forward like is
there another piece of data no this is
not a data issue
okay this is not a math problem you
could have a 400 page spreadsheet and
all the data in the world and he's still
going to be like this is a grown man
this is a grown man with an ego problem
this is not a matter we called it a
unicorn assets like this is a it could
be a unicorn asset like a duplex in
Detroit in a bad neighborhood is a
unicorn of an asset that's
is he listening to himself so we put a
lot of we purchased it it was like you
know complete the labrador all this and
everything we remodeled with a minute
and it turned out great and the
neighborhood is up and coming but it's
slow it and I'm free in six years it
hasn't moved assassin we thought and so
you know we do have profit in it which
is great but it's like it's still it's
just not I don't know the Unicorn part
he said that that's quote Unicorn oh it
sounds like something he would say
but like John said at the root of this
is not a guy who's super smart it's a
guy who there's three things going on
here there's Pride fear and greed and
maybe a little bit of all of it and that
doesn't mean he's a bad person it just
means he's gotten starry-eyed about how
smart he is and how he's the exception
to the rule and how he's gonna become
the next rich guy and one day you're
going to thank him for doing this risky
thing
but right now you're scared and you want
what's best for your family there's also
a number four detached from reality
right if he if he found a hundred
thousand dollar property in downtown
Nashville
and said honey we just need to hold this
for a second I've got a unicorn I would
go yeah you're right he did because
national properties are insane
a dilapidated refurbed duplex
where you are it's a hippopotamus it is
not a uh not a unicorn and what happens
when you guys move out and the tenants
trash the place and then the hvac's
broken and you still have a lease car
and fifty thousand dollars in debt while
paying rent while needing to pay the
mortgage and the tenants stopped paying
on top of that has he thought about that
as a possibility and see here's the
thing I think because we found really
good tenants in six years we've never
had a missed payment like we've done
great with that I think that he thinks
that that's going to be the norm like
the mobile and then like they're going
to keep paying on time we haven't had
any major expenses but we're hitting
over the six year mark now so that means
the house is going to start doing some
stuff it was built in 1900 like it was
in 1901. this is a guy that has had one
rental house one experience
George and I get to sit by Dave who's
got a whole whole bunch of rental
properties people don't pay if you watch
the news and watch what happened with
covet people just quit paying their rent
so much so that that uh politicians had
to pass laws so you couldn't kick him
out of their house because people just
quit paying they couldn't pay they
didn't have any jobs they weren't
allowed to go to work right
yeah I I wish there was a math problem I
wish there was a oh yeah just say this
but you've got a husband like those
three things George is talking about you
got a husband's detached from reality
and that has this grandiose vision of
himself and his smarts and his universe
that is simply not true the only way I
know through that is emotions